we're in a bar and someone comes up and
goes so you're together in real life
yeah the guy was like you're spongebob
and i go yeah and that's patrick and
they're like
oh my god
[Music]
hi i'm bill fingerbocky and i'm tom
kenney
[Music]
this is the wire auto complete interview
here we go what is tom kenny doing
now man just uh just working from home
every day on various stuff everything
from spongebob to rick and morty to
everything in between what is tom kenney
what is a tom kenny a tom kenny is a 58
year old
geek what is his favorite spongebob
episode
oh favorite spongebob episode that is
way out there on the internet
that is uh bad geeks of course i believe
it
i've heard him say it what is tom
kenny good adhesive what is his phone
number
grab your pens and paper everyone my
phone number is uh
is a closely guarded secret because i
hate talking on the phone if you want to
sail a paper airplane uh
through my window i'll read your message
what does tom kenny
look like he has a face made for voice
over we know that
tom kenny basically looks like every
other schlubby
caucasian man you've ever seen and
that's why voiceover is awesome
i'd be playing like confused dads on tv
right now
you call that a bathing suit nice read
what does tom kenny sound like
well it depends on the day um let's see
tom kenny sounds like a lot of things he
sounds like sponges
snails he sometimes sounds like french
guys saying two hours later
sometimes he sounds like the mayor i'm a
powerpuff girl said sometimes he sounds
like the narrator on the powerpuff girls
basically tom kenny has multiple
personality disorder and he's managed to
make a living from that nice work if you
can get it
what is tom candy's favorite voice that
he does
you know i love you spongebob been very
very good to me i love spongebob
and some of the ones that you don't get
to do as much like uh
on a show called foster's home for
imaginary friends it was a cartoon
network show
oh there was a big purple monster named
eduardo and i got to be here
the only problem was doing that for four
hours uh was like gargling drano
we call this one how bill fagerbach so
question one how do you pronounce bill
fogerbachy you can't mispronounce it i
accept
finger bacon fake and bake they're all
they're all good
i'm sure you heard them all by the time
second grade rolled around you had kind
of psyched
that's right how old is bill fogerbach
can i rephrase that
how young is bill fargo i am 63 years
old
i was born on the day the russians sent
up the sputnik and my parents called me
sputnik for about six weeks
they came to their senses and gave me an
actual name how
tall is bill fargo bucky i am six
six and a half one of the first movies i
worked on was a secret of my success
and and i was so excited to meet fred
gwynne who played herman munster
and car 54 where are you yes yes double
genius i went up and introduced myself
to him the only thing he said to me was
you're too tall for this business and he
walked away
nice to meet you how did how did phil
bogger cocky
uh get uh get uh cast in spongebob
pretty standard audition wealth no i
can't say that because it was stephen
hillenburg and nothing he did was
standard
so actually the first thing he said is i
want you to listen to this and he played
me a tape of
tom it was called spongeboy at the time
he said this is what spongeboy sounds
like
and so he said uh i want you to read for
his friend patrick what a fantastic way
to audition for something and uh
and yeah i got lucky there how do you oh
how do you meet bill fagerbach
if you're making me food we'll meet or
if you're dropping off a delivery at my
house
as you can see from bill's background he
actually lives in a tent
that's right we're accessible at comic
cons when those start up again bill and
i will do the occasional
comic-con and fans come out to say hi to
us but the bad news is you might have to
meet me too
so that's kind of good news bad news
last question on this page bill
how bill fagerbach does the patrick
voice
well i does it the way i do most voices
i take a deep breath and then sound
comes out i guess everything's down in
my torso i guess
there's a lot of room in there it's down
here as opposed to squidward who's
up here we all wonder who tom kenny
but let's take a look daddy wonders who
tom kenny who
does tom kenny this is like the match
game
who just talked any voice in rick and
morty michael says
i've been everybody from um like i'm
squanching here dude
squanchy uh to mr jellybean
to you know alien prison guard number
four
you never know who you're gonna get when
you walk in the door he just goes you're
this this this and this
who does tom kenny voice in futurama
futurama wow that was a long time ago
again that was one of those shows where
they had their main cast and they would
just bring you in and you were somebody
that they ran into
i know i was abner double deal the
commissioner of
robot boxing the episodes that most
people know me or remember
best from futurama with me is where i
was yancy fry
which is the brother of billy west's
main character fry
that was really fun people say me and
billy sound kind of alike
anyway in our nat are just regular
speaking voices it's fun to be
beat billy's brother and you know matt
granny come on who was
tom kenny in pokemon this comes up every
so often
i don't think i've ever done pokemon
there's stuff that i don't remember
like i did it and and my kids will go
hey that's your voice and i'll go i
never did that show and then they'll
point to the credits and they'll go yeah
dad that was you and i guess it was
i think with pokemon there was a guy
named tom kenny
who no bought the series and somehow got
re-dubbed it you know and got the rights
to it or or something
and made a bazillion dollars on pokemon
i
wish i was smart enough to have gotten a
hold of pokemon
no not not that smart so i don't think i
have any pokemon history
if there is the internet will slap me
around and go like
don't you remember wow i wonder if
there's another bill feigerbachy out
there that's going to
do something okay who is tom kenny
married to my wife is named jill talley
she's an actress
i met my wife on a show called the edge
then we did a show called mr show with
bob and david
and she also plays of various characters
on on spongebob in the spongebob
verse she is karen uh plankton's
computer wife
and that's that's who i'm married to she
was crazy enough to marry me
they are a fantastic couple i can attest
to that
the folks on the internet say who is tom
kenny
i why would they ask if they didn't talk
i have to answer that question myself i
will say that tom kenny is the mel blank
of our day and we are very
very lucky to have him who does tom
kenny voice in spongebob
oh wow let's see well
oh you know that pink c star this one
hangs around with i don't do him and now
it is time to move on to our
ding what bill fogger bucky round what
happened to bill
what the hell happened to you bill well
i i stepped into a big
bucket of awesome good fortune stumbling
into voiceovers um
in the 90s and and oh my god what a
fortuitous
route that was what is bill foggerbachy
like i'm a sports fan i'm a music fan
oh and i have i have two daughters that
are amazing and they're in their 20s now
bill's daughters are incredible people
and super talented in their own right
which is surprising because as children
they were horrible
no i'm kidding they were great kids too
what does what does bill foggerbocky
sing uh i'm a baritone i actually none
of this
performing stuff would have happened to
me if it hadn't been for high school
choir
i had a fantastic choir director in high
school i had the great good fortune to
actually reconnect with that acquired
director just
a few years ago and uh we had a nice
long talk and i was able to express my
my gratitude was he like why are you
wasting your talent on that silly
cartoon
what voice bill fuckerbacky do besides
patrick oh
nothing this is all i'm good for what
you see is what you get
that is not true you started out on the
cult animated series gargoyles disney's
gargoyles
still when you go to comic cons and
stuff has a devoted
cult following and you did clifford the
big red dog you did the you did uh
didn't you did you do something clifford
no you did beethoven yeah i did
beethoven
yeah so i knew it i knew it involved a
large canine what is
bill fagerbach's favorite spongebob
episode
i think i know this one aha yes he does
not mine is the pilot that's where
spongebob gets his
his job at the krusty krab because it
opened my mind to
what stephen hillenburg created you know
when dorothy wakes up after the house
lands and awes
that was me watching the pilot that i'd
already recorded i didn't get it when i
was recording it but watching that pilot
it was
wow are you saying that your life up
until then had been kind of sepia toned
and brown
just yeah dusty and windblown
you know what it turns out that when
people turn on their computers they
often say
when did tom kenny start voice acting
i kind of um began my career in stand-up
where i did a lot of characters and
things like that and then sketch comedy
with the edge and mr show and
you know it all kind of led towards just
the that pure theater of the mind where
in cartoons if you can sound like the
character you can be the character and
that's
that's really freeing to not have not
have any of this
when is tom kenney's
birthday my birthday july 13 1962
when did tom kenny start voicing
spongebob uh let's see we did the pilot
in 1997 and went to series in 1999
and now it's uh 2021 so spongebob has
been a part of my
life for at least what two-thirds yeah
maybe i don't know i'm not good with
fractions
nobody becomes an actor because they're
great at math when did tom kenny
stop voicing spongebob well
um today i'm announcing my retirement um
thanks bill for
no i'm never going to stop voicing
spongebob i hope um i never want to
retire i love what i do
and spongebob brings so much positivity
and fun and great people like bill and
everybody else on the show creativeness
creativity i'm still recording spongebob
maybe hopefully they're not just being
nice to me and then dumping my
my recordings and bringing in another
guy this one is called is
bill fogger bucky the first one is bill
fogger bocky nice
oh well i try to be i think it's
important to be nice to our fellow
humans
so i do my best it's nice to be
important
but it's more important to be nice yeah
i can say bill fogger bucky is very nice
one of the nicest people ever he never
phones it in he always brings
his a game and uh and that's no lie is
bill fagerbach in
coach i would think you could afford
first class by now first class tonight
is bill fagerbach
that was me that i was living in new
york and uh got that uh
job and uh nine years later yeah i was a
full-time resident in california
and there's still people in fact we ran
we ran into somebody with somebody who
was interviewing us or something the
other day
that had just put it together that you
that's right we're on coach right
yeah yeah yeah and then they're like
wait what and you're like wow
who doesn't know that but but this guy
didn't and he uh
it made him very happy it was nice to
watch is bill fogerbach and tom kenny
friends
oh i think so as far as i'm concerned
we're friends
frenemies would you say we're friends is
bill fagerbach on cameo
so cameo of course being the service
where people pay you to do greetings and
shout outs for birthdays and
bar mitzvahs and things who knows maybe
someday but no i
i am not it's crazy like during the
pandemic like we're just recording
all the time and there's multiple
spongebob series and projects plus all
the other non-spongebob stuff
so it's like i feel like i'm i'm up in
my
cave and you're bill you're in your cave
enough
i do enough greetings just through
people i know and friends of friends and
stuff
is bill fagerbucky on instagram no
i'm not on social media i am
just out of the loop my social media is
the texting i do
with the people i know and my friends
and family
i'm not on social media either i i've
never i've never tweeted if people find
that mind-blowing bill
people just expect that of actors now
you're supposed to be a one-man pr
department
and i just uh i'm too busy screaming hey
all you googlers we appreciate the
googling
thank you internet stay wired
oh that was smart he's smart
you